>> YOU THINK THE
SETTLES THINGS DOWN HERE.
SPINS UP AND GETSHA AND SUBBAN L
THE PUCK DID ACTUALLY GO PUSHED.
BUFFALO PENALTY NUMBER NET GOAL
SEASON.
>> THAT WAS A GREAT FACE-OFF GE.
HERE  EARLY ON TO, THAT WAS OF .
>> I WASAS SHIFTYINGLESTADT
LAST YEAR.
HE WAS UNABLE T
GOT IT AWAY. WITH A DRAG.
TOE DRAG.
AND IT'S A NICERNER, ZACHA, TAK
PUCK.
DOWN  TO THE BLUE LINE.
WITH A SHOT, BLOCKED BE WORKING.
SECOND.G CAN HAPPEN
THEY HAVE A LOT OF CHANCES AND
THEY WANT TO PICK UP RIGHT WHERE
THEY LEFTASPLUND, WORKS IT AHEA
FOR  TRIES TO
GET IT TO HAMILTON.
AND THAT'S A
NICO  SAVES ON THE NIGHT.
HIS TEAM HAS COME BACK
>>> THEY ARE STARTING TO COME IN
IN TO THE ZONE BY HADEN.
GRAVES FOR THE GAME AT ONE.
THIRDSHOOTS.
LOOSE PUCK BY SEVERSONS.
AND FIVE
STARTING 3 ON 3 BACK.
GIVE TO ZACHA.
SHOOTING,